este fallo de la corte de derechos
humanos europeas seguramente va a
aumentar la tensión diplomática
creciente especialmente en los últimos
años entre rusia y el reino unido-
seguramente podremos esperar una
reacción del gobierno británico dada la
importancia de estos hechos dado que
además el gobierno de gran bretaña ha
responsabilizado también a rusia por
estos hechos una investigación
adelantada por la justicia de este país
estableció que el asesinato de alexander
litvinenko con polonio en 2006 era de
autoría directa del presidente vladimir
putin que he hecho que ha sido
directamente negado por el mandatario
ruso y también por su gobierno en otros
hechos también la justicia británica
condenó e identificó a denis herger como
el tercer responsable por el intento
también de asesinato aquí en suelo
británico del ex agente ruso serguéi
skripal y su hija giulia en 2018 en la
ciudad de soul sur y aquí en inglaterra
recordamos que se utilizó una agente
químico llamado no que hecho que
despertó la solidaridad y la condena
internacional también sea
responsabilidad responsabilizado por
parte del reino unido al presidente
vladimir putin pero también como en el
caso del ibicenco ha negado cualquier
reacción cualquier vínculo con este
hecho